what difference would it make if China
invaded Taiwan
uh that would probably lead to the end
of the Chinese system as an
industrialized economy in less than a
year
um why that's fascinating
it's an open question of whether or not
the Chinese could pull it off uh and
with the Ukraine war we finally got some
good signposts of what it might look
like the Chinese have always assumed
that the war would be a walkover that no
one else will get involved and that
China is such a big place that everyone
will just suck it up and move on
well that clearly hasn't happened with
Ukraine and the United States and the
West have a much tighter relationship
with Taiwan than they do with Ukraine
Ukraine was only preparing for this war
for eight years Taiwan has been
preparing for 60. uh Ukraine can you can
walk to Ukraine from Russia it's a bit
of a swim to get to Taiwan uh the
sanctions that are in place against
Russia would absolutely devastate China
because well Russia has a lot of faults
it's a major export of food and energy
China Imports those things
75 of their oil is imported from a
different continent
uh and 75 of their oil is imported
and then I think it's really the
boycotts that have really scared the
Chinese the most
the idea that individual citizens might
have any say on policy
they had they did not see that coming
they have no way to process that in a
one-man State because if you want
something different to this setup that
they have yeah exactly so every
assumption that they've based the last
40 Years of military planning on has
proven to be wrong
and then of course there's the question
of whether they could actually do it
if they did a slow motion mobilization
like the Russians did it took three
months the Taiwanese would see that
they'd build a few nukes and so
the cost of capturing Taiwan would be
losing Shanghai and Beijing
that doesn't seem like a good plan so
the only battle plan that I've seen that
might work is if they just text every
member of the army and say go to a port
get on a fishing boat and sail
you'd lose a million people in The
Crossing
just to get to the beaches
so there's nothing about this that works
and if they did pull it off even if they
do capture Taiwan they are now cut off
from Global manufacturing Global
investment Global energy and Global Food
truck stop running within a couple of
months the lights go out in less than
six and that is all she wrote remember
agriculture is an industrial sector so
you're talking about Mass famine in
under a year
dude
now normally I'd say the Chinese aren't
stupid they wouldn't do this but it's a
one-man show now and nobody wants to
bring Giani information because they
don't know how he'll react he's shot the
messenger literally so many times that
everything is a surprise to him
yes I understand what you mean I suppose
there's a lot of criticisms around the
fact that the vote of a stupid person is
worth as much as the vote of a
well-educated person in a democracy but
the problem is if you condense all of
that power down to a single individual
the decision of an angry or grumpy
individual is the same as them on a good
day or them if they were less idiotic or
somebody else had got to power so yeah I
suppose uh it's a forcing function that
condenses all of these things down to
one individual human that is just as
fallible as the rest of us maybe even
more human is perfect
every time okay
but even a minor mistake just Cascades
through the system and it's a full cult
of personality so you know we've got
basically people who are zealotously
trying to do what they think she wants
them to do and just one of the more
inane ones is seeing teams of people in
Hazmat gear disinfecting airport runways
because they think that's what you have
to do for covid just that people talk
about the Americans now in a fact-free
Zone that's nothing compared to what's
going on in the Chinese system what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
space
[Music]